marieclaude jarot ne présentera sa liste
que le 13 février prochain mais elle est
déjà partie en campagne dans un
centreville de montsoléine que la
candidate place au cœur de ses projets
le centreeville souffre près de 70
commerces fermés tout simplement parce
que le centrreville a été écartelé entre
des grandes surfaces à l'extérieur à
côté du côté de l'embarcadaire avec des
projets pharaoniques et puis un
centrreville qui qui ne s'y retrouve
plus r jar ancien maire de la ville
fidèle à ses valeurs Gaulistes a fédéré
autour d'elle une équipe sans étiquette
précise--elle en 2008 alors candidate
UMP elle avait récolté 39,53 % des voix
contre plus de 53 % pour Didier matthus
c'est donc reparti pour l'actuel leader
de l'opposition ça fait tout simplement
6 ans que je me prépare à cette à ce
projet avec une équipe une équipe
renouvelée une équipe qui sera au
service des
monséliensl 2008 premier tour avec 1200
voies d'écart sur marieclaude jarot
didier matthus est candidat pour un 4e
mandat il sera à la tête d'une liste de
gauche renouvelée à 50 % mais ne
rentrera en campagne que dans quelques
semaines moi je suis maire avec une
équipe municipale qui a la
responsabilité de conduire les affaires
municipales jusqu'au 30 mars donc il
n'est pas question de rentrer en
campagne trop tôt nous rentrerons en
campagne à la mi-février le précédent
scrutin avait été marqué par plus de 40
% d'abstention à montsoléine en 2014 le
candidat socialiste actuellement sans
mandat national craint-il un vote
sanction je crois que les gens font la
différence entre l'élection municipale
ou encore une fois on choisit un maire
et le contexte national qui est d'une
autre nature sur lequel on peut porter
des jugements différents absent il y a 6
ans mais arrivé 2è au derniè cantonnal à
montsoéine le Front national présentera
une liste le Front de Gauche aussi elle
sera menée par André Gilo un instituteur
en retraite de 64
ans